[موسيقى]
جزاء الغيم تنهمر الحروف
لها نغم يحس به الشغوف
يرى فيها غصوننا باسقات
على اطرافها تدنو القطوف
[موسيقى]
فان لبثت مقاليد المعاني مسطره تنوء بها
الرفوف
فتحنا في صميم العلم بابابا فقال الدهر قد
جاز الوقوف
[موسيقى]
من جلب در الكلام
حلب در الكرام السلام عليكم
[موسيقى]
اصل الظلم في لغه العرب ومعانيه في القران
الكريم الظلم وضع الشيء في غير محله فكل
من وضع شيئا في غير محله فقد ظلم واكثر في
القران اطلاق الظلم على الشرك يقول تعالى
والكافرون هم الظالمون ويقول ايضا ولا
تدعو من دون الله ما لا ينفعك ولا يضرك
فان فعلت فانك اذا من الظالمين وقالت
العرب لمن يضرب لبنه قبل ان يروب ظالم لان
ضربه قبل ان يروب يضيع زبده وقيل للارض
العذراء التي حفر فيها ولم تكن محلا للحفر
ارض مظلومه لان الحفر وقع في غير موضعه
يقول النابغه الذبياني الا الاواري لايا
ما ابينها والنوء كالحوض بالمظلومه الجلد
ومن هنا قيل للقبر ظليم لانه حفر في محل
لم يحفر قبل ذلك يقول الشاعر فاصبح في
غبرها ابعد اشاحه على العيش مردود عليها
ظليمها وفي القران الكريم يطلق الظلم
اطلاقين الاول بمعناه الاعظم وهو وضع
العباده في غير من خلق والثاني يطلق على
ظلم الانسان نفسه ببعض المعاصي وفي هذا
المعنى قوله تعالى ثم اورثنا الكتاب الذين
اصطفينا من عبادنا فمنهم ظالم لنفسه ومنهم
مقتصد ومنهم سابق بالخيرات
[موسيقى]
دخلت امراه من البرامكه على هارون الرشيد
ومعه جمع من العلماء والبلغاء فحيته
بقولها السلام عليك يا ايها الامير يا من
حكمت فقست اتم الله نعمتك واقر عينك وفرحك
بما اتاك فرد عليها هارون وعليك السلام من
تكونين يا امراه فقالت انا من الذين قتلت
رجالهم وانهبت اموالهم وسلبت نوالهم قال
اما رجالهم فقد نفذ فيهم حكم الله وجرى
عليهم قدره واما المال فمردود اليك ثم
التفت الى جلسائه سائلا افهم ما قالت
فاجابوه ما نراها قالت الا خيرا قال اما
قولها يا من حكمت فقصدت فاخذته من قوله
تعالى واما القاسطون فكانوا لجهنم حطبا
واما قولها اتم الله نعمتك فاخذته من قول
الشاعر اذا تم امر بدا نقصه ترقب زوالا
اذا قيل تم واما قولها اقر الله عينك
فمعناه سكنها والعين اذا سكنت عمي صاحبها
واما قولها وفرحك بما اتاك فاخذته من قوله
تعالى حتى اذا فرحوا بما اوتوا اخذناهم
بغته فاذا هم مبلسون
فاندهش الحاضرون لقدره المراه على التوريه
وفهم الامير لما اضمرت
[موسيقى]
نقول في السرى سرى الرجل اذا سار في الليل
وفي المثل عند الصباح يحمد الساري سراه
ادلج الرجل سار في اول الليل والدلجه سار
في اخر الليل وقد قال احدهم مقيدا الفرق
بين اللفظتين
وادلج الانسان ثم الدرجا اي سار والليل
البهيم قد جاء فالسير في اوله ادلاج
والسير في اخره الدلاج
[موسيقى]
تقول العرب في امثالها حسبك من شر سماعه
فما قصه هذا المثل
زعموا ان هذا المثل ورد على لسان ام
الربيع العبسي وكان ابنها الربيع قد اخذ
درعا من قيس بن زهير بن جهيمه فعرضها قيسا
لام الربيع وهي على راحلتها في مسير لها
اراد ان ياخذ ام الربيع رهينه حتى يرجع
ولدها الدرع الذي سلبه اياه فقالت له ام
الربيع اين ذهب عقلك يا قيس اترى بني
مصالحيك وقد ذهبت بامهم يمينا وشمالا وقال
الناس ما قالوا وشاءوا وان حسبك من شر
سماعه اي كفى بالمقاله السيئه عارا وان
كانت باطله
يضرب هذا المثل عند العار والمقاله السيئه
وما يخاف منها وقيل ان القول لعاتكه بنت
عبد المطلب عمه رسول الله صلى الله عليه
وسلم
[موسيقى]
كثيرا ما نسمع قولهم فوض له الوكاله وفوض
له الامر والصحيح ان نقول فوض اليه
الوكاله او فوض اليه الامر يقول الفيروز
ابادي في القاموس المحيط فوض اليه الامر
اي رده اليه ويقول زين الدين الرازي في
مختار الصحاح وفوض اليه الامر تفويضا رده
اليه وورد في القران الكريم حكايه عن مؤمن
ال فرعون قوله تعالى
فستذكرون ما اقول لكم وافوض امري الى الله
ان الله بصيرا بالعباد
[موسيقى]
بعض الاماكن
مثل المرايا تنظر فيها فلا تريك ما تراه
العين وانما تريك ما ينطبع في الذاكره قد
تريك مكانا اخر بعيدا غائبا ولكنه اشد
حضورا في النفس مما تقع عليه العين ولقد
كنت في غرناطه فرايت فيها ماضي دمشق ونظرت
في دمشق فرايت ماضيا عرفته غرناطه
وعرفه اهلها
يا موجع القلب من شام واندلسي
مازلت تذكر لكن الزمان نسي هل ضلت الفرس
الحمراء غايتها ام جاءك الليل
ينعى مقتل الفرس طال السرى وخيوط الشمس ما
وصلت ما عدت تشعر بالاصباح والغلس هذه
المدينه مراه مزخرفه من صورتين الم نشرح
ومن عبس تريك في الغرب ماضي الشرق مختلقا
وفي بلادي صدى التفتيش والعسس
غرناطه او دمشق نص مقتبس ما اشبه الاصلب
المنسوخ والقبس الفرق ما بين ماضيها
وحاضرها كالفرق بين اذان الفجر والجرس
معموره من صلاه الخوف اسقفها مصابه نائحات
الورق بالخرس محروسه في مدى النسيان ذاكره
تقول اياك ان تبنو من الحرس تخضر للداخل
المنصور نخلته واليوم كل نخيل صار لليبس
[موسيقى]
في فقره وسم احيانا اطرح سؤالا ثم اسال
نفسي ما الذي دعاني الى طرح هذا السؤال
هذه المره سالتكم ما اسوا شيئا عرفته
البشريه
طبعا وردتني مشاركات كثيره استعرض معكم
بعضها بعض المشاركات اخذت جانبا فلسفيا
والبعض الاخر كان مفاجئا نوعا ما والبعض
كان تقليديا جدا على كل حال نستعرضها معا
هذه مشاركه من اناس تقول كتب المفكر
المصري الرائع عن الهاشمي ذات مره الحداثه
وما بعد الحداثه دينا الهه الهوى وكهنته
الاطباء والنفسيون وليس افسد للبشريه من
دين هذا الهه وهؤلاء كهنته
مع ان الاطباء النفسيين حاجه ملحه صراحه
في هذا الزمن وفي كل وقت
وابو محمد يقول الانترنت او بشكل ادق
وسائل التواصل الاجتماعي يقول قطعت كثيرا
من العلاقات الجميله التي كانت بين الناس
صارت الضحي صارت الضحكه الحقيقيه عباره عن
فيس ممكن
ترسله وانت معبس
معاذ السلمي يقول موت الضمائر وما اكثرها
في زمننا هذا
ومشاركه من احمد حماد يقول الثوره
الصناعيه يا رجل شو مشكلتك مع الصناعه
الطيارات والسيارات والامور بالعكس والله
الحمد لله عيسى المناعي يقول الحسد
كثيرون قالوا الحسد وكثيرون قالوا وسائل
التواصل الاجتماعي ولكني اخذت فقط واحد من
هنا وواحد من هناك لكن فعلا يعني الحسد
نال نصيبا كبيرا محمد المعاضيد يقول
التكنولوجيا
وربما يقصد كما قصد يعني صاحب المشاركه
السابقه وسائل التواصل على كل حال يعني كل
امر من هذه الامور له وجهان وجهه خيرا
ووجه شر
صفوق مشى عليه يقول الفقر
الفقر لو كان الفقر رجلا لقتلته علي
الزئبق يقول دوام يوم السبت
واشرف يقول او ظلم والظلم ايضا نال حظا
وافرا من المشاركات كثيرون قالوا الظلم
يحيى يقول السوشل ميديا
وليث يقول المكياج
[موسيقى]
وصديق يقول الواسطه فعلا الواسطه اذا كان
من شانها ان تقلب الخير الى شر والحق الى
باطل فهي
امر من الامور السيئه جدا في المجتمعات
انا ارى ان اسوا شيء عرفته البشريه
هو التكبر
الكبر يؤدي الى الغرور
والغرور يؤدي الى سوء التقدير وسوء
التقدير يوردك المهالك انظر الى ابليس حين
تكبر وقال خلقته من
خلقته من طين او خلقتني من نار وخلقته من
طين وكيف ابى ان يسجد
فيعني خرج من رحمه الله
على الجمله
التكبر هو اصل كل الصفات السيئه والشريره
ومن التكبر
تنبع العنصريه والشر
والاعتداء على الناس واعتقاد
الاستحقاق الكاذب فتعتقد ان شيئا ما حقا
لك وهو ليس لك بحق
هذه وجهه نظر غير منزهه عن الخطا طبعا
وجهه نظر شخصيه
واشكر لكم هذه المشاركات وهذا التفاعل
[موسيقى]
وحدثكم عن مشاعر قال يوما دع المكارم لا
ترحل لبغيتها واقعد فانك انت الطاعم
الكاسي
جرول ابن اوس ابن مالك العبسي مع اختلاف
في نسبه وامه امه اسمها الضراء كنيته ابو
مليكه وغلب عليه لقب الحطيئه لقصره
ودمامته ولد في الجاهليه واسلم في خلافه
ابي بكر الصديق رضي الله عنه
ادرك الحطيئه بعض فحول الشعراء الجاهليين
وخصوصا زهير بن ابي سلمى الذي جالسه وروى
عنه وتاثر به يرى بعض النقاد ان دوافع
الحطيئه الى قرض الشار كانت تدور حول
النواقص الحاصله في نسبه وخلقه ووسائل
كسبه والذب عن نفسه وبيته كان الحطيئه
شاعرا مقتدرا جزل العباره عميق المعنى من
اشعر من عاصروه في صدر الاسلام طرق اغلبيه
اغراض الشعر واجاد فيها وان كان غرض
الهجاء غلب على شعره واحتل اكبر حيزا من
ديوانه
من ابلغ امثله شعره في القصص قوله يصف كرم
اسره عربيه
وطاوي ثلاث عاصب البطن مرمل ببيداء لم
يعرف بها ساكن رسما وافرد في شعب عجوزا
ازائها ثلاثه اشباح تخالهم بهما الى ان
يقول
راى شبحا وسط الظلام فراعه فلما بدا ضيفا
تسور واهتم فقال ابنه لما راه بحيره ايا
ابت اذبحني وقدم له طعما ولا تعتذر بالعدم
على الذي ترى يظن لنا مالا فيوسعنا ذما
فروق قليلا ثم احجم برهه وان هو لم يذبح
فتاه فقد هما فبين هما عنت على البعد عانه
قد انتظمت من خلف مسحلها نظما عطاشا تريد
الماء فانساب نحوها على انه منها الى دمها
اضمى فخرت نحوصا ذات جحشا فتيه قد اجتنزت
لحما وقد طبقت شحمى فيا بشره اذ جرها نحو
اهله ويا بشرهم لما راوا كالمها يدما
قصه جميله
وفيها
السرديه الحوار مع الولد حين جاءهم الضيف
وليس عندهم شيء والولد يقول يا ابتي
اذبحني وقدمني طعاما للضيف وبعد ذلك يعني
يتهيا هذا القطيع من بقر الوحش فكيف
يصيدها ويقول انها هي ضاميه للماء ولكنه
هو اضمى اليها منها الى الماء ثم يقدمها
الى ضيفه وهكذا هذه الابيات اذكر انها
يعني كانت من المقرر في المدرسه اتوقع في
المرحله الاعداديه من جيد المدح عند
الحطيئه قوله في ال شماس بن انف الناقه
يقول اقل عليهم لا ابى لابيكم من اللوم او
سدوا المكان الذي سد اولئك قوم انبنوا
احسنوا البنا وان عاهدوا اوفوا وان عقدوا
شدوا وان كانت النعماء فيهم جزوا بها وان
انعموا لا كدروها ولا كند
الى اخر الابيات
من جيد شعره في الحماسه قوله وغاره كشعاع
الشمس مشعله تغدو بكل صبيح الوجه بسامي
قبي البطون من التعداء قد علمت ان كل عام
عليها عام والجامي جمعت من عامرا فيها ومن
اسد ومن تميم وذبيان ومن سامي وما رضيت
بهم حتى رفدتهم من وائل رهط بسطام باسرامي
الى اخر
الابيات يرى بعض النقاد ان تكوين شخصيته
وظروف حياته رسخت فيه هوايه الهجاء حتى
اصبح الغرض الاول عنده وسيمه البارزه
لشاره من ذلك انه اكثر من هجاء الزبر قال
ابن بدر فتحمل الزبر قال كلما قال فيه مع
ان الزبرقان سيد قومه الى ان قال الحطيئه
للزبرقان دعي المكارم لا ترحل لبغي تها
واقعد فانك انت الطاعم الكاسي فشكاه
الزبرقان الى عمر بن الخطاب رضي الله عنه
فعزره عمر وزجره وسجنه فتره
بعد خروجه من السجن هجبا العجلان فشكوه
ايضا الى عمر فاستدعاه بحضرته حسان بن
ثابت رضي الله عنه وقال اسمعه ما قلت في
بني العجلان لنعلم هل يراه شتما فانشد
قوله قبيله لا يخفرون بذمه ولا يظلمون
الناس حبه خردل ولا يردون الماء الا عشيه
اذا صدر الوراد عن كل منهل وما سمي
العجلان الا لقولهم خذ القعبه واحلب ايها
العبد واعجلي فقال حسان يا امير المؤمنين
راه فعل كذا وكذا عليهم وافقدهم الذمه
وصورهم اضعف الناس فهم عمر بقطع لسانه غير
انه خاف ان تكون عقوبه مبتدعه
فسجنه وبعد ايام من السجن ارسل الحطيئه مع
سجانه كتابا الى عمر ضمنه ابياتا يستعطفه
فيها ويقول
باسم الذي انزلت من عنده السور والحمد لله
اما بعد يا عمر ماذا تقول لافراخ بدي مرخ
زغب الحواصل لها ماء ولا شجر القيت كاسبهم
في قعر مظلمه فم عليك سلام الله يا عمر
فانت راس قريش وابن سيدها والراس فيه يكون
السمع والبصر نعم الفتى عمر في كل نائبه
نعم الفتى عمر نعم الفتى عمر فاطلق عمر
سراحه وصالحه على ترك اعراض الناس مقابل
مبلغ من المال فتركها مؤقتا رغبه في المال
وخشيه من صرامه عمر وفي تلك الفتره اقتصر
هجائه على نفسه ومحيطه الخاص
يقال انه نظر في بئر فراى انعكاس وجهه على
الماء فانشا يقول ابت شفتاي اليوم الا
تكلما بسوء فما ادري لمن انا قائله ارى
ليوجه شوه الله خلقه فقبح من وجه وقبح
حاملا هذا قوله عن نفسه وفي يوم من الايام
التمست منه زوجه بعض مؤن العيال
ولوازمهم فرد عليها بشائر يقول فيه لها
جسم برغوث وساق بعوضه ووجه كوجه القرد بل
هو اقبح وتبرق عيناها اذا ما رايتها وتعبت
في وجه الضجيع وتكلحوا وتفتح لا كانت فمن
لو رايته توهمته بابا من النار يفتح فما
ضحكت في الناس الا ظننتها امامهم كلبا يهر
وينبحُ اذا عاين الشيطان صوره وجهها تعوذ
منها حين يمسي ويصبح وقد اعجبتها نفس ها
فتملحت باي جمال ليت شعري تملحوا عاد
الحطيئه الى الوقوع في اعراض الناس بعد
وفاه عمر رضي الله عنه واستمر على ذلك ما
عرضه للسجن والمضايقات بقيه حياته الى ان
توفي في حدود سنه سبع واربعين للهجره
من يفعل الخير لا يعدم جوازيه لا يذهب
العرف بين الله والناس
انا ابن المانعين حمى الاقاصي وجاري القول
بالفعل الفصيح متى اضع العمامه قيل وافت
سمو الراي في الراس الفليح ومن عجب
يطاولني قصير مطاوله ويسترجي
مطيحي سيرتفع الغبار بغير وزن ولا يبقى
سوى الوزن الرجيح اذا رفع الزمان سفيها
قوم لعمرك ما يصح سوى الصحيح السلام عليكم
[موسيقى]